Hi, I'm Katie Stiles with "Before and After TV".
Today, I'm going to show you how you can effectively furnish...
...and decorate a small space.
This living room is approximately 180 square feet.
With the use of sleek and modern furniture...
...and a streamlined entertainment system,...
...you can actually make your space appear bigger and define the room.
And I'd like to share my ideas with you.
So here we have a really comfortable, beautifully furnished room.
We've made great use of a small space by using very sleek leather couches.
They're not too big.
Sometimes people use the oversized couches.
They're accented with some nice pillows.
What I love about this room is the large, bold print carpet.
And a large carpet will elongate a room, make it appear bigger.
What I also really love is the use of ottomans in place of a coffee table.
A large coffee table can take up way too much space in a small room...
And with the ottomans, you can move them around,...
...you can use them as seats, you can use them as side table...
...or right in front of you as a coffee table.
A really important thing is not to clutter a small space...
...so pick your decorative items carefully.
Make sure that they are amongst your favorite...
...and that they reflect your personality and your style.
Of course, for your entertainment system,...
...a plasma TV or a flat - screen TV works really well in a small room...
...because you don't lose all of that wall space.
And I love modern - meets - old by placing the plasma on top of an antique cabinet.
As you can see, it's really quite easy...
...to effectively decorate and furnish a small space.
Use a mix of your existing pieces combined with some new ones...
...and all you have to do now is sit back and enjoy.